hello I'm David Tomlinson and I'm
responsible for the global Geographic
strategy and operations within Accenture
and have recently moved my relocation to
Shanghai I'm here at World Economic
Forum and have just finished a panel on
the subject of India beyond numbers how
can India be a shining star I thought it
was a fascinating debate and my takeaway
is that we could look at all the
challenges in India but what wonderful
opportunities for India to really be a
rising star yeah with what population
demographics which could be viewed as a
challenge but also a wonderful
opportunity to me I took away the key
priorities are around infrastructure how
to get things done looking at education
making sure education is producing job
relevant skills health care but
underpinning all of this how information
technology and particularly broadband
access in rural communities access to
mobile devices can really help transform
society and maybe create the
opportunities for India to leapfrog to
the future I feel very optimistic for
India as a great nation thank you